شهدت منصات في ليبيا حال كبير من الغضب
الشعبي بسبب مقطع فيديو من داخل مستشفى
مجدل عام في ليبيا واللي من صدر اسمها
ترند على الفيسبوك من امبارح مقطع الفيديو
هو بث مباشر لعمليه ولاده قيصريه لامراه
كانت مسافره من الجنوب الليبي للشمال
واضطرت الى الولاده القيصريه في المستشفى
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على سلامتهم يعني بس الفيديو
اللي شوفتهم مشاهدينا تم البث واللايف على
صفحه مستشفى مازدا العام على فيسبوك من
بدايه العمليه لنهايتها وبنشور من دون
اخفاء للملامح ولكن احنا اضطرينا بصراحه
انه نخفيها احترام لخصوصيه الام وطفل كمان
اللايف هذا عمل حالك كبيره من الغضب
والجدل على المنطاد والناس استعجنت اللي
صار واعتبروه انتهاك لاخلاق المهنه ولا
حرمه المريض وطلبه وزاره الصحه الليبيه
باتخاد الاجراءات القانونيه اللازمه
والتحقيق مع الطاقه الطبي اللي صور
العمليه وفي ناس شافوا انه عادي اللي صار
والمريضه حبه تتشارك هاي اللحظات مع
عائلتها
ولكن من بعد الغضب الشعبي والمطالبات قام
المستشفى بحذف البث المباشر من صفحته على
الفيسبوك نشعر بيان قال في انه تصوير
عمليه الولاده تم من بعد ما تم اخذ الاذن
من الام اللي هي طلبت انه يبثوه عمليه
الولاده مباشره كون عائلتها في الخارج
وحبوا يطمنوا عليها وعلى الطفل بينما وصف
مدير المستشفى علي الكباشي الحمل اللي
تعرض لها المستشفى من بعد البث بانها غير
منطقيه وان العمليه القيصريه مثلها مثل
غيرها من العمليات عادي بتلبسها وتوثيقها
بالصوت والصوره وقال انه طلاقم الطبيه عم
بتمر في حال من الاحباط من بعد الهجمه
عليهم عبر السوشيال ميديا لكن على الرغم
من البيان والتبرير رده فعل الرافدين للي
صار هي اللي بقيت